[Music]
along welcome everybody my name is Z
Boyer and I'm the technical lead for
architecture components thank you so
today we are going to talk about what is
new in architecture components but
before we start with them let's look at
what we have been doing in the last two
three years so three years ago were
talking to developers and they were
saying oh Android development is so hot
so hot like what is hot about Android
development and they started listing
things like life cycles persistence like
a lot of things are just hot you know so
we needed to pick something we said okay
we are going to first create an
architecture guidance and we're going to
tackle some of the major problems we
think are important so we started with
life cycles and persistence so two years
ago at i/o being an Austin
soon after we have added paging because
we realize people struggle with that
making it efficient and then in last
year's i/o we have added work manager
and navigation to the fog all these five
libraries together had more than a
hundred and fifty releases in two years
the second release every five day and
based on the latest survey 70% of
professional developers use one of those
libraries in their applications so thank
you
[Applause]
this is a like very amazing adoption
number for us and let's look at how we
are doing it so every project starts its
life with an early access program so
once we know what we're playing to do we
send it to some developers ask for
feedback after we are comfortable with
that feedback we release a public alpha
which is when we are still developing it
actively but it is ready for to show
everyone after some time we become happy
with the functionality and the api's and
we call it beta when we call something
beta that means the API will not change
anymore so you can write code and that
code will still keep compiling and
eventually the library becomes stable
soon after the library becomes stable we
always go back to alpha and a beta so
this cycle keeps turning
we heard that like many people are
unhappy because everything is in alpha
all the time this is because of it you
can happily use the latest stable
version but we want to develop in the
open and we want this rapid iteration
cycle and all of this is possible thanks
to the community so we do a lot of user
experience research we talk to the
whoppers they keep these the Whopper
Diaries while they work they do really
regular work at work they look what
they're doing and tell us how it is
going we do a lot of one-on-one
interviews with developers to better
understand the problems we do early
access program so that before showing it
to everybody we can talk to a closer
group more in-depth and get initial
feedback issue tracker where you report
your bugs and feature request is very
important for us that's what we use to
prioritize features and bugs last but
not least we close the follow things
like reddit stack overflow to see what
the community is thinking so yesterday
we have announced that is going to be a
cutting first for Android so this means
we are not going to just release KTX
libraries we are going to release more
coding focus libraries we some of them
will be written and Kotlin to take
advantage of the better language
features so it means some of the api's
will first target Kotlin and then we
also support the java programming
language so during the today in this
when you talk about these new features
you will see a lot of coding okay so
let's start the libraries and we'll
start with the oldest library we have
data bindings so if you don't know data
binding data binding is our declarative
UI since I'd XML it tries to bridge the
gap between your coat and your XML
so if you have a layout like this if you
put these layout tags around it you'll
get a binding cause if you add variables
as inputs to that layout they become
setters and getters in this binding
class and then you can use these
variables in your layout and declare
what you want to show and data binding
takes care of showing it this last one
year we've been heavily focused on the
tooling part of data binding so we've
significantly improved the compilation
speed it's not 20% faster while we run
the annotation processor we had this
support for distributed Gradle cache so
that if you if you're using in your
company you benefit from your peers
compiling the project last but not least
in three point five now we have an
incremental annotation processor for
data binding it's experimental so you
need to turn it on with this flag so
please give it a try
and let us know how it works so other
part of data mining is tooling
integration which is studio so we did
out of work here so one of the things
we've improved is how the live cost
generation works so on the left here I
have this binding clause associated with
the layout on the right and if I want to
access this textview I can just go ahead
and then give it an ID so when he really
has an ID it becomes a field in the
binding cost and here immediately
without compiling the project I have
that field in that binding object so you
don't need to wait as
think so but if you're using data
whining this is not how we update the
views right you can also do it with a
variable that's actually how you will do
it in data wrangling so we go ahead
change it we had this header as a
variable to the layout as you can see
all autocomplete works we get rid of the
ID because we don't need it instead
we're just going to say text this header
as you can see code completion works
here too on the left it immediately turn
red so just go ahead and fix it so all
of these works without waiting for
compilation so another important thing
is refactoring so I have a user object
here on the left which is a variable on
the right and in one of the expressions
I access that and call a function on
that user object now if I go to the
class and say I'm gonna rename this
function I'm gonna call it say combined
name so as soon as I make this change
and it entered Andros to do updates my
binding abstraction automatically for me
and you can do the same thing from XML
and it will update your code last but
not least we know data binding error
messages has been a huge problem that
like you will have any problem in your
compilation you will get a thousand
errors so we fix that problem we have
also added a section in your output the
specific to data binding errors so you
can easily discover them so similar to
the data binding like how do we access
views on androids let's locate all the
options we have we're gonna emulate them
in terms of elegance the compile time
safety and the build speed impact so
first we have the good old find me by ID
it's not elegance very verbose doesn't
provide any compile time safety you
don't know what type you are receiving
but it doesn't have any build speed
effects so that's good you could use
data binding which provides a very nice
API with the compile time safety but it
runs an annotation processor so it does
slow down your build
you could be using butter knife
similarly it's another annotation
processor so it's going to slow down
your belt now if you are incontinent
you could use common synthetic accessors
that provides partial compile time
safety is a very beautiful API but it
and also it doesn't have any build speed
impact but we are looking for this like
something that has a green checkmark in
all of these things they should be
possible and we don't need to look far
to discover this so if you look at this
data mining we see a lot of people using
data binding like this they put IDs to
the views just to get this binding
course on the right no variables no
expression so what do we just call this
we're binding so real binding is a new
feature it's going to be available in
Android studio 3.6 that's the next
versions
[Applause]
so now let's go back to the previous
example we had these layout techs
they're not necessary we don't have
variables so we can get rid of it it's
just a regular layer takes a mouse so if
we had it from our activity we will
access it like this but you don't want
this fine view by this so control all of
it out and instead we can use the
generated binding costs inflated and
then set the content view and now we are
going to have all of the wheels with IDs
as public final fields in that object so
you get perfect compile time safety
because if the ID with the correct type
doesn't exist your code you've just not
compiled and you can also use it from
Java so thank you so we all of these
binding calluses are generated by the
Android Gradle plug-in so it doesn't
need to do any extra work unless you
change your layout file and if you
change a layout file only that file gets
invalidated so it's very fast during
incremental compilation it is
hundred-percent compile time safe so if
your code compiles you know those views
exist in the right layouts it has full
studio integration similar to what I
have shown for data binding earlier and
speaking speaking of data binding it is
completely compatible with data binding
in fact if you are using data binding
just access views you can turn it off
and turn on your binding and your code
will compile as is okay now we are going
to move to lifecycle and I'm going to
invite Saiga to tell us more about it
thank you
thank thank seed
good morning everyone my name is Sergey
and I will give a quick update on life
cycles so what we did two years ago is
first of all introduce the way to
observe events from your fragments or
activities so you know we're started or
resumed and so on
we introduced few models that is
retained state across configuration
changes kind of a starting point for
your non you iPod and lastly life that
is just observable that have a good
default behavior
so observe replay cycle but before
proceeding to new stuff we had to talk
about that after i/o I read on the
internet list and I was like what's
going on I don't agree with that at all
and I have to explain now like why why
this confusion exists and why it's not
true so the picture is kind of like that
so it's going to be flat explanation at
the beginning so you have your stuff you
put your stuff into view model or a safe
state configuration change happens you
go to your view model safe state and
grab your stuff out of there
is it the similar mechanisms well
actually no so let's take a closer look
only on safe state part same setup you
put your stuff into the safe state when
we talked about configuration change
well actual purpose of safe state is not
configuration changes we it is created
to help you with process death because
system when your application the
background may decide well we need this
memory for some other task and kill your
application but because Android wants to
provide nice user experience what we do
is once the application restarted we
give you hints this a statist with hints
to you how to recreate the state that he
had before and the user seen before so
how does it actually work and it once
stabbed
so once you put your safe state let's
have a vase a state what actually
happens safe state travels to the system
server system server is a separate
process so varies like this travel
across process boundaries and this gives
us very specific restrictions on what is
assisted it's not a stuff it's a data
it's possible data
it's just what we call sterilizable
android so our primitive types and i
also we have this data limit on the size
of it because otherwise well system can
keep like gigabytes of data for every
application and then serialization
actually takes time as well so it just
won't work so this is a say state so
let's take a look on the view models
well in a country's to say state we
model always live in a process memory
then it never leaves it so configuration
change doesn't affect it anyhow at all
it just memories continuous your view
models still their process doesn't die
so your stuff is there so however one
application whether the process is
restarted well it's in process in every
process dies everything there goes away
and then your application is restarted
from a view model perspective you have
nothing so you can see every handle
different situations and the model are
for like keeping references to your non
serializable things like network
requests and flights or database queries
well it doesn't mean that you actually
have to write these things there but
it's kind of a provides the scope for
them and other things that you can keep
there is a big objects like a long list
of that I acquired from database and
need to keep somewhere or images that
are relevant only for that fragments
specifically well safe state is this
your eye base like selection on the
scroll State and navigation state this
is like more interesting for us what it
doesn't mean so once to show let's say a
screen the future profile
you want to know what user you show last
time so you need to keep user ID in this
negation state so we will see this
example in a second so as you see we
model and say state work together we not
we shouldn't like be opposed so let's
see how this you use your example so
your view model will look like this you
have a user I mean you have a life that
of this information how you would do
this remodel plus-sized state and all
the way well this is fairly poor little
traitors in oncreate who go to the
bundle paths with information from a
bundle down plus the view model on safe
state you go in reverse failure
boilerplate and what we did we
introduced a way to contribute to say
state from the model right away
so now you can receive this state state
handle object right in your view model
constructor and this object will allow
you to access say State right into your
view model so what is this it's very
simple it's much like object meaning
that it has very straightforward API you
just put stuff and get it once you put
it what later when your application is
recreated the model is recreated it
receives a state handle the information
that we put by the key will be available
to you again so you can query by the
same key we also give you nice
convenience API if you use live data you
can instead of just get data you can
observe it in a usual way and because
say state is mutable because otherwise
it will be a constant no need to save it
we you can we give you immutable like
that and you can write as you would do
it usually so last slide on this theme
is provided by my manager actually say
set is not your database no matter which
way you use alt on create an unsafe
instance state or this new convenience
API or
fragment arguments underlying mechanisms
are the same so you still have this
restrictions about what you can put
there on the size limit on in so it
won't just work and we go to in our fame
so cotton is everywhere lifecycle aren't
exceptions yesterday we had a talk about
coral since a lifecycle if you missed it
you can find it on the Internet
we introduced a bunch of new place and
looking for a feedback and we kind of
made our depths and other fields of life
cycles for example stem conversions were
broken for a long time
a for life data so you can see it
doesn't look like natural course in code
and now it does you can have this lambda
after observe all similarly
transformations looked very unnatural
because we have a systolic method on
transformations and you know it's just
not the way you do that and cousin
instead of that you have extension
functions we did that and last thing is
we model in civilization we kind of a
force you to have this late in it war
and it's you know a bit of a cold smell
people are get worried when you see it
ends for for reason or nullable view
models so now as I said with property
delegation you have very concise syntax
you just initialize the view model and
that's it
[Applause]
and actually that's it for life cycles
and I hand out for Samir who is going to
present a work manager and a bit of it
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Samir Kataria and
I am an engineer on the Android team I
want to talk to you a little bit about
work manager today for those of you who
don't know work manager is a background
processing library for work that is
specifically deferrable meaning that it
doesn't have to be executed right away
this has also work that's persistent so
it can go across app restarts it can go
across device restarts so it needs to be
persistent this is worth that's
constraint based so you can have work
that only triggers when you have a
network connection for example or other
constraints and finally this is work
that's backwards compatible so it goes
all the way back to Ice Cream Sandwich
API 14 before I go to actually top
priorities we released a stable version
of work manager 1.0 a couple of months
ago so I want to thank everybody who
participated in the alpha beta early
access program thank you very much so
our top priorities moving forward
there's three of them that I'm going to
talk about today one is performance and
compatibility the next is testing and
finally building for the future so
things that are more forward-looking so
let's talk about performance and
compatibility the first thing that I
want to talk about is on-demand
initialization it's available now in
alpha so please check it out so one of
the things that you might have noticed
with work manager is that it needs to be
initialized when your app starts up this
is more or less a hard requirement
currently and this on-demand
initialization will allow you to start
work manager only when you need it which
is really good for avoiding critical hot
paths like app startup this is not
something that you need to worry about
anymore you can just use it when you
actually need it let's take a look at
how this looks so right now you might
have your application class you might
have customize it so you have a my app
and in work manager 2.1 alpha you can
extend or actually implement
configuration dot provider override this
method and this returns a work manager
configuration so this is all work
manager needs to know on where to get
the data now currently in
work manager to dot oh you get work
manager get instance and you don't
provide any arguments in starting in 2.1
if you provide this context argument
this is work manager signal okay if I'm
not initialized I can go to the
application object get the configuration
and do a lazy initialization when I'm
needed so that's all it is it's very
simple the second thing I want to talk
about here is Google Play services
integration and this is coming soon so
this basically will allow you to have
better performance on pre marshmallow
devices and it's totally optional you
don't really need to integrate it if you
don't want it and if you do want to
integrate it it's just a simple great
old dependency that you add nothing else
because there's no API changes under the
hood it'll see if you have Play services
if you're using it it'll use it on pre
marshmallow devices and compatibility
improvements this is an ongoing project
for us and this is not something that
you'll necessarily see in our code base
or in our releases but it's stuff that
we do behind the scenes and I want to
talk a little bit about it so we've
noticed that there are a few differences
in devices and manufacturers for example
if you go to the recent of your device
and you swipe away an app on a stock
Android device or on a pixel device
you'll notice that the process gets
killed but on some devices you might see
that the app gets for stopped and forced
off is a really destructive action in
the case of for stop your jobs get
stopped and wiped out actually your
alarms get wiped out you don't no longer
receive FCMs for stuff is a very
destructive action so we're working with
OEMs to have a consistent app close
behavior here we want to make sure that
everybody has the same app close
behavior which is really good for
libraries like work manager which
operate in the background the next thing
I want to talk about is testing when we
launch work manager a couple of months
ago we kind of had a problem at Robo
electric support in that it didn't work
we fixed it it's out in stable sorry
about that and also now we have an alpha
unit testing for workers so basically
you can create your workers using one of
these two classes just worker builder or
test listenable worker builder
and you can just use them by using the
do work or start work method as is
appropriate so let's take a look at that
in action so let's say you have a work
request you can use a test worker
builder and you can say create that work
request from a given context and a given
executor - on which it will run you just
build it so this gives you a worker
class back and then you can call the do
work method which is the method you've
already overridden to do the and get its
result you can assert the result you can
check the state of your app make sure
everything's fine so that's how you
would unit test the worker if you're
using a listenable worker same thing you
start with a work request and you use a
test listenable worker builder and you
can say create that use creative worker
using that request you build it and same
thing instead of calling do work in this
case you call start work remember that
test that list of all workers are
asynchronous and to control their own
execution so you don't need to specify
an executor here and it artwork returns
a list of all future so you just call a
blocking get on in this case and you
assert that everything is the way you
want it to be you can even provide more
arguments so you can say something like
here's the input data for it here's the
run attempt count that you're currently
on here's the tags that you have for
this worker and the last thing I'm gonna
talk about is building for the future
and this is in particular we want to
have foreground service support and work
manager and this is very much in
progress so this is not ready this is
later in the year you'll probably see
something about this but the basic idea
is that what if you could do work in the
foreground using the work manager API
and this is particularly useful I was
just talking to someone this morning
they wanted to do a long-running upload
work manager and job scheduler both give
you a 10-minute slice of time to do an
upload or whatever work you have but
what if it goes longer than that you can
use a program service for that and work
manager can make it easier for you so
because this is a foreground service
your app will show a notification talk
to us about it in the sandbox if you're
interested we want to hear what
everybody has to contribute to this what
use cases you have and so forth and now
I'd like to turn it over to Danny for
room thank you somewhere hey my name is
Daniel Santiago and I'll be talking a
little bit about room but before we get
to what's new room what is room well
room is for SQL like object mapping
library and it basically creates a bunch
of code for you based on some annotation
so that you can easily access your data
objects with a SQLite database let's do
a quick recap on how this looks
imagine we're making a music application
we're going to be saving some songs on a
database we start by having a data class
we call it song it has some ID a URL for
a room to let know that you want to have
a table for this entity you annotate it
with the entity annotation you let it
know if it's unique identifier now in a
database if you want to get the data out
of it you would write a normal
SQL query select star from Sun but to
let room know that you want to link this
query with that data class you actually
put it on a method that returns a list
of songs and it's annotated with our
query now you don't throw these methods
all over the place you actually put them
on what we call data as a subject and if
this is just an interface or an asteroid
class annotated with at thou now to link
these together you have your music
database it extends room database it has
a database annotation and then you let
it know if it's entities which in this
case will be the song and the dowels are
just scattered method in a nutshell it
kind of looks like this you have your
database your dials and your entities
and your application interacts with all
of these tools now let let's get to the
good stuff so something new that's in
room two point one is co-routine support
in room 2.0 if you try to add a suspend
method to your Dao
because you have a copy not you're using
and you probably want to do your heavy
work i synchronously you usually at your
husband method room would freak out he
wouldn't he wouldn't know what to do he
would no can do that
and this might let you to create repair
methods that are suspensions that
actually then call the actual dull
function but you can imagine this
doesn't scale very well but no worries
in room 2.1 you can actually have
diameters are suspended meted room will
generate the correct code including
using a background dispatcher you can
also have such methods with insert
update and delete and even more so you
can have suspend implemented methods
that do multiple database operations
that are annotated with a transaction so
that these database operations are done
atomically even more so there's also an
extension function on room database that
will allow you to start a transaction it
creates this special coding context that
you can use to also perform multiple
database operations now another new
feature we added in room is full text
search full text search is an extension
in SQLite to be able to create tables to
efficiently search for data thinking
back on our music app imagine we're
trying to create a search functionality
we want to search for songs given a
phrase if we were to do this in room 2.0
we will have to write a down method
kinda like this doesn't look great you
have this huge we're cause it has all
the columns like it's not great but no
worries in room 2.1 if you want an
entity to be able to be backed by a
nucleus table you simply use the FTS
annotation and now this greatly
simplifies your query because you can
start using the match expression which
is way more efficient
speaking of yeah thanks
thinking of simplifying things database
views is another way to simplify your
database separation so lot of reviews
are kind of like tables where everywhere
you will reference a table you can
reference view but they're different
because you cannot insert data
interviews to put it differently they're
kind of like queries with a given name
let's think about listing again back to
our music application this time we want
to show a list of albums and these
albums have some aggregated information
the total number of songs and the total
time in the album and thinking back how
we started using room we have a simple
data class with the information that we
need now in room 2.1 instead of having a
big query you can actually make you can
actually annotate your data class
without directly a database view and
instead of making a table we'll create a
view out of it and then to specify how
we get this information you put your big
query in the annotation and you can see
it's a big query it has aggregated
information but the important thing is
that now you can use this view or entity
as if it was another table and you can
see here we also have another order by
which you know makes your operations
easier
[Applause]
nice we've been outside adding more
support for our ex in rooms and we know
people like our ex in room 2.1 you can
have insert update and delete method
that return completable maybe in single
and even more newer we also added
support for returning our x-pipe on
query annotated down methods that
perform write statements such as update
insert and delete so for those queries
that are more complicated that you still
want to use rx you can do that now
that's one of the new things in room but
we still have a lot more work to do one
of the most immediate things we want to
do is have an incremental annotation
processor this will greatly improve the
bill performance for those of you using
room or for those of you who might start
to use room we also know that
relationship is another area of
improvement we only have a single
annotation for regulation and it helps
you with one-to-many but we feel like we
can do many too many even maybe using a
jump table so that's one area we are
trying to explore we also know that
migrations are not so great like when
you use room it creates the tables for
you but then when you migrate you also
have to call the create statement we
feel like most of the migration
operations can be done with some code
generation such as adding a new table
renaming a column things like that last
but not least as we take a look at
Kotlin and co-routines
we're keeping our eye on their API and
we'll be able to add support for
channels and flow
thanks so back to you who will be
talking to you about paging
[Applause]
thanks Danny okay let's talk about
paging so if you don't know paging
paging is our library to load Lively's
into a recycle of you lazily and it
works with multiple data source it works
with rumor I'm retrofit whatever kind of
place where you can pull the data from
so for the next version of paging our
focuses on networking and error handling
so we heard this loud and clear that is
kind of hard to channel your errors from
your network back into your UI so we are
working on a new pipeline to enable this
we also add support to change those
pages as you pull them so you can like
eject headers and footers or filter them
last but not least you're going to
improve the support for our it's Java
and add support for Cortines
so these are all in the next version of
paging we are about to start an early XX
program for it so we are doing an early
access program because we significantly
change the API so we want to get good
feedback and later in the summer you
should expect an alpha version all right
navigation navigation is a library we
release in previous IO it helps you with
your in-app UI floss so you can easily
show a graph control how the user should
navigate setup so a couple months ago
navigation became stable and we already
started working on the next version
which is already out and in this next
version we have a new feature for view
models where you can scope them to a
navigation graph this is amazing when
you have things like signup flows this
composed of multiple screens you can
just have one view model for that whole
scope
and other features you can not navigate
by a URI so you don't need to have the
IDS and you can finally use dialogues as
navigation destinations so these are all
in 2.1 but another big upcoming feature
for navigation is support for
dynamically delivered modules now it's
not ready yet this is gonna take a
couple of months to implement but it's
going to be available in navigation so
that you can just navigate as if
everything is inside the application
without thinking about dynamic features
so to learn more about all of these join
us later today at 1:30 in the jetpack
navigation Talk okay so if you're like
maybe leave to these things or trying to
get started with katli and try to get
started with architecture components we
just released a new course on Udacity
they say like a tank or session
completely online that teaches you how
to write a modern Android application
using Coplin and architecture components
this is a great resource to get started
with these technologies you can always
find detailed documentation on our
website and if you want to be involved
further in our process you can go to
this URL and see how you can participate
in our development flow thank you
[Music]
you